you know most firms would put you in
front of the bar and have your license
stripped
you lied to a client and he figured it
out yes
exactly don't lie to a client you should
not
lie to a client and defraud them
hey legal eagles d james stone here
teaching you how to think
like a lawyer today we're tackling a fan
favorite highly requested
suits now i've never seen a full episode
of suits before
but i'm guessing from the title that
it's about a group of men
who wear suits you can tell i'm i'm very
perceptive about these things
as always if you see any legal or
factual inaccuracies
please leave me a comment below in the
form of an objection
if you object i will get to it and i
will either sustain
or overrule your objection but let's dig
right in oh and by the way
stick around until the end of the
episode where i give suits
episode 1 a grade for legal realism so
you won't want to miss that
but without further ado let's dig into
suits episode one
first of all gerald if you think
anyone's gonna touch this deal after
your bad faith you're mistaken
second the way our agreement works is
the minute cooper signed the deal which
gave you everything you wanted
our fee was due and payable which is why
at 7 30
i received confirmation of a wire
transfer from escrow
indicating payment in full
wait is is the deal done or not that no
transaction on the planet would have
someone transfer a huge amount of money
um before the deal is consummated now
there are companies that
deal in this sort of thing they're
called escrow companies if there is an
amount that is going from one company to
another
then you give your money to an escrow
company they hold it until all the deal
terms are complete
and then they turn it over when certain
criteria are met
if any lawyers drafted a deal that had a
wire transfer going before
the the terms are complete that's
probably malpractice so this is
this is crazy i don't know what deal
they're talking about but that would not
happen
we got paid before gerald signed the
deal what are you talking about this is
a memo about some fire drill on tuesday
huh you're the blue team captain you get
to wear a fire hat okay
all right so uh what this person has
done is called
fraud he has made up facts that are not
true
in order to induce someone to enter into
an agreement
when you induce someone based on fraud
that is called fraud and the inducement
and when you commit
fraud in the inducement that deal is
null and void because you fraudulently
got them to enter
into a deal so uh if this deal goes
through
and the other guy finds out that he's
been lied to in a fraudulent manner
that deal is no longer done and it would
be unwound and the whole thing would
just blow up so
that's not good lawyering good lawyers
don't lie good lawyers
use the facts as they exist in the real
world
to make sure that all the parties get uh
their best deal
they do not lie in order to consummate a
deal that's
that is bad lawyering that is
malpractice and it might be a crime
all right so he's an lsat cheater
[Music]
and he hit his he hit his test so that
no one would know that he cheated
hey stop
this is really interesting lsats or the
law school entrance exam
is very important it's how you get into
a good law school it's how you get into
any law school
so it's not surprising then that given
how important the lsat
is uh there is some cheating now the
board that offers the lsat has tried to
combat
cheating so they require you to bring in
a driver's license or other valid form
of id
and they check that when you enter and
when you leave
but sometimes people get around that
given how important it is it's not
surprising
that there are some really nefarious
people out there who are going to try to
game the system
and try and get a good lsat score
because it can
change the course of your entire career
what did you get i said i was gonna get
you a 158
i told you i wanted a 175 and i told you
only one out of 100 people can score
that
that's right if you score a 175 that
means you're in the 99th percentile
actually you're well into the 99th
percentile of the lsat it scored from
120 points
to 180 points so if you score a 175
that means that you are basically in the
99.5 percentile
that is very very high and so he's not
exaggerating when he says
a 175 is only procured by one out of 100
people
and he said he scored a 158 that's not a
great score that's probably
in the 80th or 85th percentile so not
bad
but certainly not a score that's going
to get you into
one of the top tier law schools out
there so it's funny that he's
complaining about the score that he
cheated and got from this guy we need
people who think on their feet not
another clone with a rod of his ass
harvey the fact that we only hire from
harvard gives us a cachet that's a
little more valuable than hiring a kid
from rutgers
you went to harvard law i'm an exception
find me another one all right so the
recruiting process
is a fascinating process in law school
and with firms that i could talk about
for hours suffice it to say
there are firms that only hire from
certain schools now there probably
aren't any
law firms that hire only from harvard
you're probably gonna
hire from the top five or the top 10 or
the top 20 law schools
but there are law firms that are very
picky about where they get their summer
associates from
now a summer associate is a law firm
specific term it means
someone that's in law school usually
this is someone who is in their second
year of law school their second
year summer and they are basically
interning
for the firm and if you like that person
at the end of the summer
then you'll give them an offer to come
work for the firm
when they graduate from law school
that's what they're saying when they're
saying
they are looking for a summer associate
that's a very common thing for big firms
to look for
so it's cool that they get that that
lingo down that's absolutely accurate
great thanks okay done
we're gonna need to streamline this give
each guy a hard time
before you send them back give me a wig
if they say something clever
cool okay what are you looking for
another me okay this is great
he's interviewing the law students at a
hotel which is exactly
where law students tend to get
interviewed for these what are called
on-campus interviews
now i went through the process in los
angeles i assume the process is pretty
similar in new york
the law students all enter their names
into a lottery
then you send everyone to a hotel you
get a bunch of
associates or junior partners in the law
firm to
hang out in a hotel room the law
students come
in and they conduct their interview so
so far that aspect of the recruiting
process in law school
is is spot on it's so funny i've never
seen that in a tv show before
so ship what makes you think that i'm
gonna let the whitest man that i have
ever seen
interview for our firm because i have an
[Music]
appointment and lawyers have all kinds
of criteria as to how they choose people
for callbacks these are screening
interviews they're just going through
dozens if not hundreds of law students
and if they like you then they send you
for a callback where
you'll be interviewed by a bunch of
attorneys at the law firm itself so
you're really churning and burning in
the hotel and it
it's funny that this guy has a criteria
of they have to say a witty remark
[Music]
you want this job so much why don't you
just go to law school
when i was in college it was my dream to
be a lawyer i needed some money
and trevor convinced me to memorize this
math test
and sell it
turns out we sold it to the dean's
daughter i lost my scholarship i got
kicked out of school
i
i got knocked into a different life
that there's some truth to that in law
school
and especially when you're trying to
become a member of the bar
they look at your moral character and if
you have a blemish on it
you're going to have to explain it now a
youthful indiscretion
with no follow-up conduct and no
criminal record
i don't think that's going to be a huge
barrier to becoming an attorney
you will have to explain it to the board
but it shouldn't preclude you from
entering into the profession for your
entire life you just have to explain it
explain that you're not going to do
something like that again i need a grown
goddamn man
you give me this and i will work as hard
as it takes to school those harvard
douches and become the best lawyer you
have ever seen
i'm inclined to give you a shot but what
if i decide to go another way
i say that's fair and sometimes i like
to hang out with people who aren't that
bright
you know just to see how the other half
lives move over
i'm emailing the firm i just found our
next associate
the problem here is that he has ethical
limitations as well
and if he is knowingly sort of
conspiring to have someone who's not a
member of the bar
participate in these activities that is
a huge problem both for
mike but also for harvey because he's
the one that's sort of knowingly
subordinating it so he may have run into
ethical issues
himself that might result in him losing
his bar license uh by knowingly hiring
someone
that isn't an attorney to do attorney's
work so
big problems there for both of them
gerald tate fired the firm
so you're taking my promotion away you
know most
firms would put you in front of the bar
and have your license stripped you lied
to a client and he figured it out
yes exactly don't lie to a client you
should not
lie to a client and defraud them and
oh my god he's a client not the opposite
side why would you even lie
to your client you're not even trying to
close a deal from the other side
this i mean you have an ethical
obligation to
do what your client wants or to get the
outcome that your client wants
to lie and defraud your own personal
client
he should be disbarred for that that's
that's crazy
don't do that pro tip don't lie to your
client
no more shenanigans you do one more
thing that isn't straight as an arrow
and instead of covering your ass i will
put you in front of the bar myself
mike hey who's ready for a great first
day
i'm gonna have to let you go that's
probably a good thing to do with just
being lying to a client
and if they find out that i lied about
you going to harvard oh and by the way
the whole partnership model of a law
firm means that the partners have joint
and several liability
so if one of the partners conducts some
horrible fraud on their client
the whole partnership is at risk at that
point so
you know you got to be really careful
and you have to worry about what your
other partners are doing so to cover up
for a partner who is defrauding and
ignoring their own client to bully them
into a deal
that is that is not good this sperm is
not going to exist for very much longer
um i'll give you your promotion
but you have to do something for me
anything boy just
digging it deeper pro bono anything but
that harvey
pro bono cases are how we as a firm show
that we care about more than just
ourselves i'm not saying we shouldn't do
them i'm saying i shouldn't do them and
it's how
a lot of lawyers feel that way about pro
bono work you generally have an ethical
obligation to
do some pro bono work during the year so
you can help
those who can't afford the large fees
that most law firms command
but that being said some lawyers really
hate doing it some lawyers really like
doing it because you can get
experience that you wouldn't otherwise
be able to procure like
going to trial more often than not or uh
you know working one-on-one with a
client when you're a junior associate
you often don't get those uh those
opportunities
but if you're a senior partner you can
understand why they don't want to take
that away from their billable practice
still kind of a dick move though one
night and he says that if i sleep with
him he's gonna take care of me in the
firm
and if i don't he's gonna fire me so
what did you do
i went to human resources they said they
investigated couldn't find anything to
support my claim i wasn't looking for a
payoff
all i wanted was for it to stop can you
help me
uh yes yes i can
so generally speaking there are two
types of sexual harassment there is
the hostile work environment sexual
harassment where
by the actions of someone it creates a
environment that is
non-conducive to working that makes
people feel uncomfortable so such that
they can't work there
and you know that's generally referred
to as creating a hostile work
environment you're not allowed to do
that
but the second type of sexual harassment
that is
really uh less common because it's so
much worse and so much more explicit
is quid pro quo sexual harassment which
is what this person describes where
you are conditioning a job or a
promotion
or some perk on uh some sexual favor and
it's a really terrible thing it
definitely happens
thankfully it's more rare than it used
to be
so if that client is to be believed that
is a classic case of quid pro quo
sexual harassment totally illegal but
it's very hard for victims of that kind
of harassment to
prove uh what has happened because it's
a classic case of he said she said
i don't know how to fill out a subpoena
come on genius how hard is it to fill
out a form donna can you show me how to
fill out a subpoena
absolutely and after that you want me to
show you how to wipe your ass it's funny
because you should already know how to
do both those things
no no no summer associate would know how
to do that
just right off the bat now true he could
look at the form and he could probably
muddle his way through
but the funny thing about that is if he
files a subpoena with a court
or sends a subpoena to the other side
and signs it he has
effectively pretended to be an attorney
and engaged in the unauthorized practice
of law
which would get basically all of them
disbarred especially
him so everyone there at that firm has
a obligation to make sure that he does
it right and they shouldn't be
chastising him
for not knowing how to fill out a
particular form and in fact for any
summer associate
if they fill out a subpoena or discovery
request
then an attorney is going to have to
review it and sign it and if you
sign that you are basically saying that
it's as good as if you did it yourself
and it is accurate and it complies with
the law
and you can be sanctioned as if you
wrote it yourself you cannot allow a
summer associate
to uh take credit or uh practice law
so all their asses are on the line here
they should not be
uh chastising him for this this act of
filling out a subpoena
okay i have two words for you absolutely
beautiful
you think you're the only one who can
term a client categorically stunning
so what most people don't know about
being a big firm attorney
is that without clients the firm can't
operate
so generally there are a couple
different types of partners one
are the partners that just bill like
crazy they're
often the best attorneys they're the
ones that really put in the hours and
they're bringing revenue
into the firm now there's another type
of partner which
are the rainmakers the people that more
focus
on bringing clients in now both of those
types of partners are important because
without clients
there's no work to be done so often
an attorney's job is not just the nine
to five
court pleadings and and dealing with
transactions
there's a lot of client management where
you have to
make sure that there are more clients
coming in so that you have work to do in
the future they filed a motion to
dismiss the case based on our lack of
evidence
good good what do you mean good
they don't want to hand over the files
you press word hurt you're looking in
the right place
did you think they wouldn't fight back
well i now that you mentioned it
oh all right so that doesn't make any
sense at all emotion to dismiss
is a motion that you file on the basis
of the pleadings so
they're the plaintiff here they filed
what's called a complaint which lays out
their whole story that she was fired
and uh the other side is allowed to
either
file an answer to that or file a motion
to dismiss in most jurisdictions
the part that doesn't make any sense
here is that the motion to dismiss
takes the allegations and the complaint
at face value so there's no evidence at
this point
that there's been no opportunity for
discovery there's been
it's also been just a couple of days so
these things take months
um but you can't file a motion dismiss
on the basis the other side
doesn't have any evidence because no one
has gathered any evidence yet
so that doesn't make any sense i care
about this woman
she's got nowhere else to turn and you
can't help her by yourself
i can i just prefer not to
this is a really good example of why you
would never hire
someone who did not go to law school and
doesn't have any legal experience
the law and being a lawyer is all about
application it's not about the
memorization of facts
i can go online and i can look up what
the rule is what the law
is i can look up the case law i don't
need to have a photographic memory
to make a good argument i will look up
the authority that is relevant
the idea that this guy would be a
cracker jack associate
when he simply on the basis of reading a
bunch of law books
makes no sense and it's why
realistically he needs to ask for help
from people who have experience
because they're the ones that can help
him because they've been in the trenches
on this kind of stuff
so it's good of him to ask for help
that's what a junior associate should do
but he's not going to be a good attorney
just on the basis of having a good
memory
okay you're asking a look at private
files without any evidence of your
assertion yeah but the only way that we
can find the evidence is to look at
those files
but is there precedent
oh my god this is such a stupid
discovery battle
discovery allows you to get evidence
from the other side and
you don't have to make a positive
showing in order to
get that evidence as long as you can
demonstrate that the evidence
that you could potentially get is
related to the
allegations that you've made in your
complaint or are related to
defeating those allegations or are
relevant to your defense in the case
then you should be able to get that
information you know bounded by
things like privilege you can't get
things that are necessarily privileged
or trade secrets or things like that
but if there was a rule that said you
had to have evidence before you could
get evidence
well no lawsuits would ever happen so
this is this is a stupid argument that
they're dealing with this is not the
kind of discovery dispute that you're
gonna deal with as an attorney
i'd like to think herman would come to
me before it even got to an
investigation
i saw that that should be stricken well
what if herman did come to you your
honor there's nothing to strike
there's nothing on the record trust by
firing him under false pretenses
you really think that a little of me i
wouldn't trust you as far as i can throw
you
your honor
hand over the files today of course he
has to
well that's true okay it's a little
ridiculous to hand over the files today
usually you would have several weeks to
go over the files and then turn them
over you have to be able to review them
before you turn them over to the other
side
you have to check for things like
relevance you you don't just get
access to millions of pages of documents
just by requesting them but this whole
dispute is kind of insane
every civil case goes through what's
called discovery it's the process by
which you ask the other side
for information and the other side has
to turn that over
unless they can show that there's a
reason not to sometimes that reason
is because it's privileged sometimes
that reason is because
it's not related to the lawsuit and even
if they were able to get that
information it wouldn't relate to the
claims that they're making
but you always have to engage in some
discovery and it seems like this company
is just saying you have
filed a sexual harassment claim against
our company and you should not be
entitled to any documents whatsoever
well as you can imagine that doesn't fly
you always need
some documents and the company that is
the defendant
is going to be the one who possesses
those documents so that this is a
dispute that would never happen
they're trying to bury you in paperwork
well
they picked the wrong guy if they didn't
i did
get it done by the end of the week i
gotta run and try my new client
yeah so this is a tactic that actually
happens you
uh often see big companies try to bury
the other side in paperwork especially
if they are going up against
a small firm or a solo practitioner that
doesn't have the infrastructure to be
able to review all of these documents
however any major law firm and this
appears to be a major law firm in this
tv show
has in-house document review systems and
what they allow you to do is to scan
thousands and sometimes millions of
pages of paperwork
and to run word searches on it not to
mention
this kind of tactic of trying to bury
the other side in paperwork is highly
disfavored by
federal and state courts and if a party
tried to do this to me and give me a
huge dump of paper files
i would turn around go straight to the
judge and say this is ridiculous they're
trying to drive up our costs
and uh asked them to give it to me in
electronic form or if i couldn't do that
then
demanded the court give me a court order
ordering them to turn it over in
electronic
two months later i was fired for having
a bad attitude
this is ridiculous wipe that smirk off
your face you're not even supposed to be
here
you really you don't want that guy in
the room during this deposition
no good can come from that after working
for devlin mcgregor you
then went on to waitress at hooters
right
yes i did a place that advertises the
sexuality of his weight staff correct
you'll have to ask them that i'm asking
you
and she's not answering all right this
is good this is actually what a
deposition
looks like you sit in a conference table
you've got attorneys on either side
sometimes you have a party
representative and you have a
stenographer who's taking down
everything that's said for the official
record so this is a fairly accurate
representation of what a
big firm deposition looks like i'm sorry
you you were arrested in your past and
you lied about it here under oath
is that making it seem different than
what it is
no answer all right yeah at this point
harvey and mike should be objecting like
hell they should be instructing the
witness not to answer and they should be
chastising the other attorney for
bringing up the subject
which was a criminal matter when she was
a minor
but also was under seal how did this guy
even get that information
i don't know the rule with respect to
whether or not she can be found
liable for perjury in this particular
context when the subject was sort of off
limits to begin with
but all of this is wrong they should be
up in arms they should be
shutting this deposition down none of
this should be on the record at this
point
you can save your breath there's no way
i'm testifying at the hearing tomorrow
that's not why i'm here i know what you
did what are you talking about you never
worked for devlin mcgregor
and you're never harassed by mr hunt
that's a lot look i could tell you that
i've got the cancelled checks or the
wire transfer or whatever smoking gun
okay here's why this doesn't make any
sense they're hinting that
the other side hired a witness to
testify
that the defendant sexually harassed her
in some sort of
quid pro quo sexual harassment and then
she was going to basically purge her
herself
and admit to not being truthful about a
prior crime when she was
17. that doesn't make any sense because
her testimony is still
on the record she testified that he
sexually harassed her
so they hired someone to provide
evidence for the other side now true
they might have to deal with the fallout
of her being shown to be not the most
trustworthy person
but that testimony is still on the
record they hired someone they paid
someone
to give horrible testimony about the
defendant that
they're not even witness tampering right
it's crazy
wire transfer from your account to
joanna webster's
phone records with joanna webster prior
to her testimony
in an affidavit stating you paid miss
webster to falsely testify
but again she falsely testified against
the people that hired her
that that's not even the way you would
want a witness tamper that
they paid someone to give testimony
against themselves it's
it's totally insane what do you want an
admission of guilt
and a guarantee that you'll obtain
treatment before working again
again there's nothing for him to admit
guilt for
except maybe witness tampering if that
is an actual criminal
crime this is a civil case for sexual
harassment
quid pro quo sexual harassment and he
needs to pay
the plaintiff money and there might be
an admission of
liability but the most important thing
is that he's going to compensate her for
the wrongs that she's done that's how
the
civil system works you put people in
jail
to punish them for crimes against really
the state and the people in general
you are civilly liable for things that
you've done to an individual in this
case
sexual harassment all rise
that was suits episode one a lot of
things going on there a lot of moving
pieces so how does it stack up against
the real world what grade does it get
well let's see in terms of the
recruiting process in law school that it
gets spot on
and there was a lot of brilliant legal
arguing marred only by the fact
that every single one of those attorneys
would have been disbarred
so all in all i give it a b-minus they
get some things right but a lot of the
legal argument is wrong and all of those
attorneys would have been disbarred
so if you like this video please
subscribe for more legal analysis and i
put together a playlist
with all of the legal react series if
you like this video you'll love the
other videos on
a few good men my cousin vinnie law and
order so click on the playlist and i'll
see you in the next video